ici Céline Galipeau de Kiev en Ukraine à
défaut d'une victoire Vladimir Poutine
lance un appel patriotique pour
poursuivre la guerre la région de kerky
résiste depuis 3 mois ses habitants
rentrent chez eux pour reconstruire plus
au sud la vie quotidienne sous les bons
brutes un cursus dans la petite ville
d'origine
ce soir au Téléjournal
[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames messieurs bienvenue à
cette édition spéciale du Téléjournal
qui sera entièrement consacrée à
l'Ukraine ce devait être une journée
symbolique pour Vladimir Poutine il
voulait profiter des cérémonies du 9 mai
qui marque la victoire des troupes
soviétiques contre l'Allemagne en 1945
pour présenter aussi la victoire en
Ukraine ça n'a pas été le cas la Russie
n'a pas de grands succès militaire à
faire valoir ici alors sur la place
rouge devant des milliers de soldats
russes il a plutôt tenté de justifier
son offensive et il a comparé ce combat
à celui de l'Armée rouge contre les
nazis
on profite donc de l'occasion pour faire
le point sur ses 75 jours de guerre avec
mes collègues en Ukraine Jean-François
Bélanger en Suède qui envisage de
joindre le temps Marie-Eve Bédard et
plus près en Moldavie petit pays qui
redoute que le conflit gagne ses
frontières Tamara Alteresco et je
commence d'ailleurs avec vous Tamara
parce que comme correspondante à Moscou
vous en avez couvert plusieurs de ces
défilés militaires qui se veulent une
démonstration de force mais celui
d'aujourd'hui il était différent à cause
du contexte bien sûr
absolument Vladimir Poutine s'est servi
aujourd'hui de cette date sacrée pour
les Russes afin de justifier sa guerre
alors qu'il est incapable de la
remporter vous savez il a fait comme il
fait chaque année il paraît son armée
ses chars c'est blindés s'est mis cils
pour dire regardez comme l'armée russe
est forte organisée
disciplinés sauf que dans les faits
cette armée a été mise à l'épreuve pour
la première fois depuis très longtemps
et elle a carrément échoué et vous savez
pour avoir comme vous l'avez dit couvert
plusieurs de ces grands défilés à Moscou
dans les rues du centre-ville au fil des
ans c'était impossible de ne pas penser
à ces milliers de soldats qui sont là
d'habitude sur la Place Rouge avec
Vladimir Poutine qui aurait dû être là
cette année mais qui brillait par leur
absence soit parce qu'ils sont au front
au moment où on se parle ou encore parce
qu'ils sont morts et enterrés et vous
savez les Russes ne savent pas combien
de soldats sont morts on parle peut-être
de 25000
maximum ils ne savent pas parce que le
Kremlin ne leur dit pas Vladimir Poutine
a évoqué ces soldats aujourd'hui très
brièvement pour dire que les familles
seraient compensées mais ces femmes ses
frères ses enfants qui pleurent leurs
proches eux savent le prix à payer pour
ce qui considérer une opération spéciale
donc ce qu'on a entendu aujourd'hui le
discours de Vladimir Poutine c'était
pour une consommation interne en Russie
ce qu'on a vu et entendu sur la Place
Rouge c'est un président qui a voulu
expliquer aux Russes pourquoi cette
guerre doit il va continuer on peut
écouter un extrait de son discours
aujourd'hui c'est que les soldats de
l'armée se battent pour défendre la même
cause qui était défendue en 45 par leur
père et leur grand-père il continue
d'entraîner sa population dans son
univers parallèle selon lequel l'Ukraine
est nazi et de père avec l'Occident avec
le temps plus particulièrement
représente une menace imminente pour la
Russie
plusieurs attendaient à ce qu'ils
profitent de ce discours pour faire un
coup d'éclat peut-être déclarer la
guerre officiellement à l'Ukraine or son
discours il a été très court comment
est-ce qu'on explique cette sobriété
cette retenue
je pense qu'il faut y voir peut-être un
calcul stratégique de la part de
Vladimir Poutine au risque de paraître
prévisible ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il tient encore tout le monde
en haleine à savoir comment il va
entreprendre cette troisième phase en
fait ce qui considérait une troisième
phase de la guerre ceci dit c'est pas
parce qu'il a pas profité du 9 mai pour
annoncer une mobilisation générale qui
ne pourrait pas le faire demain ou dans
les semaines qui suivent d'ailleurs il y
a beaucoup de rumeurs à cet effet en
Russie c'est un scénario qui est
appréhendé redouté même je vous dirais
il y a des hommes qui rapportent déjà
avoir reçu des courriers dans lesquels
ils sont convoqués à des examens
médicaux obligatoires est-ce que c'est
vrai est-ce que c'est encore de la
propagande on ne le sait pas mais je
pense qu'il faut voir aussi dans la
retenue de Vladimir Poutine peut-être
une nouvelle qui qui est malheureuse et
c'est que la guerre est en train de
s'installer et que pour lui il faut lire
dans son discours même s'il ne l'a pas
dit dans des mots que l'échec n'est pas
une option pour Vladimir médecine et
vous savez au moment il faut regarder
les gestes qu'ils posent aujourd'hui
au moment où les Russes célébraient
cette journée de la victoire il y a
quelques heures à Moscou il y avait des
feux d'artifice mais ici à 150 km à la
ville était à nouveau bombardé et ça ça
s'est produit au moment où le président
du Conseil européen était en visite et
l'industrie réfugiés dans des
souterrains ça je pense qu'en soi c'est
plus fort que des paroles c'est un
message sans autre pour l'Occident qui
continue de fournir à coup de milliard
des armes à l'Ukraine
l'Ukraine donc qui est en guerre
maintenant le plus de buts trois mois
merci beaucoup Tamara justement on va
vous retrouver tout à l'heure pour
parler de la Moldavie ou les
gouvernements sont tous en état
d'extrême vigilance on peut dire
à plus tard
[Musique]
Moscou il a promis que l'Ukraine ne
laisserait pas la Russie s'approprier la
victoire sur le nazisme il sait aussi
dit confiant de remporter une victoire
prochaine contre les forces russes
alors deux mois et demi après leur
entrée en Ukraine ou en étant sur le
terrain pas de grandes victoires à
présenter on l'a dit pour Moscou seule
une ville importante est tombée jusqu'à
présent la ville de Kerson au sud les
Russes ne contrôlent pas encore
complètement Mario Paul qui a été
pourtant mise à feu et à 180% des
bâtiments seraient détruits mais les
derniers combattants symboles de la
résistance ukrainienne refuse toujours
de capituler à l'usine d'azophtales
ailleurs dans l'Est les forces russes
piétines voire même recul et nulle part
n'est aussi clair que là où vous êtes
Jean-françois dans la région de quartier
vous savez c'est la deuxième plus grande
ville du pays c'est donc dire
l'importance stratégique qu'elle revêt
une importance symbolique aussi parce
qu'il faut savoir qu'une majorité de
gens ici ont en commun le russe comme
langue maternelle donc beaucoup
s'attendaient en 2014 à ce que les
habitants de cette ville-là se joignent
au mouvement sécessionniste prorus comme
l’ont fait les villes de deniès et de
lougans mais non les gens ici ont choisi
plutôt de rester fidèles à l'Ukraine
même chose cette fois-ci ils se sont
battus avec détermination pour résister
à l'armée russe et depuis quelques
semaines on assiste à une 40 offensive
d'envergure d'ailleurs les forces
ukrainiennes ont gagné beaucoup de
terrain au cours des derniers jours ce
qui leur a permis de prendre le contrôle
de plusieurs dizaines de villes de
villages au nord et à l'est du pays et
donc on commence à voir maintenant des
habitants qui sont tentés par un retour
chez eux comme vous allez le voir dans
ce reportage tourné aujourd'hui avec
Emilio Avalos dans la petite ville de
villefiveca
la maison d'Alexander et de lumila n'est
pas si loin une quinzaine de kilomètres
à peine mais si rendre représente
aujourd'hui un long périple par se met
dans bus des points de contrôle
et des carcasses de blindé calcinés
autant de vestiges des violents combats
qui se sont déroulés ici
le village de villefka est en bonne
partie détruit
mais un calme relatif il est revenu
depuis que les soldats russes se sont
retirés
alors Alexander et Luna en profite pour
revenir voir leur maison
aussitôt accueillis par regick le chien
des voisins qu'il croyait mort un
soulagement
mais leur maison elle est empiétrita
voilà dit-il à quoi ressemble la
perruche
un obus tombé dans le jardin à ravagé la
façade les dommages sont importants
précise-t-il et personne ne va nous
forcer à partir d'ici moi
ajoute Ludmila et personne ne nous a
rendu si fort et s'y unie que Vladimir
Poutine lui-même personne nique toi
cette maison c'est pour eux le fruit de
40 ans de dur labeur
regardez les impacts de base dit-elle
c'est comme ça que tout a commencé
comme beaucoup dans la région de
karquises Alexander et lune Mila sont
d'origine russe et il ne supporte pas
d'avoir servi de prétexte pour cette
invasion
c'est comme ça les supposés soldats de
la paix russes sont apparemment venus
nous libérer d'elle nous les russophone
mais de quoi exactement
[Musique]
en sortant le couple prend des nouvelles
des voisins ceux qui sont restés sur
place comme vassiliorinjin 87 ans il n'a
pas bougé de chez lui pendant toute
l'occupation pas question pour lui de
partir malgré le danger malgré cette
requête tombée dans son jardin
le vieil homme se sait miraculé et en
attendant la visite des démineurs il a
jury de rester il se sent d'ailleurs
bien plus en sécurité depuis que les
soldats russes ont quitté les villes et
les villages situés au nord et à l'est
de carquive et la raison pour laquelle
la situation est un petit peu plus
sécuritaire ici c'est que les forces
ukrainiennes sont en train de mener
depuis plusieurs semaines une vaste
contreensive contre les soldats russes
on voit d'ailleurs ici la préparation
d'une de ces opérations ce qui a eu pour
effet de repousser les Russes parfois
même jusqu'à la frontière avec leur pays
donc de desserrer les taux autour de la
ville de carcive qui est presque
maintenant entièrement hors de portée de
l'artillerie russe
cette unité spéciale de l'armée
ukrainienne s'appelle Thumann brouillard
et ses hommes cachent difficilement leur
fierté car le terrain reconquille au
prix de très grands sacrifices et d'une
importance stratégique capital le
commandant l'unité se fait appeler crâne
et il reconnaît que les soldats russes
sont plus nombreux et mieux équipés mais
il affirme que ces hommes sont plus
mobiles et qu'ils connaissent bien mieux
le terrain
[Musique]
et notre détermination sans faille
dit-il
c'est notre terre nous protégeons notre
Mère Patrie nos enfants notre avenir
dit-il il n'y a pas de meilleure
motivation
au reste son bras droit nous amène au
bunker pour nous montrer les armes
récupérées des combattants russes en
déroute
des cadeaux de la Russie comme ce dragon
9 un fusil de sniper en même temps
il nous montre aussi un autre cadeau
beaucoup plus utile
unla une arme antichard britannique qui
a permis de détruire quantité de blindus
il en profite pour lancer un appel aux
pays occidentaux
de soutien dit-il nous sommes sont
motivés mais nous manquons d'équipements
spécialisés des lunettes de visée
nocturne par exemple
cette aide selon eux et le seul moyen de
terminer rapidement cette guerre et donc
de limiter les pertes en visuelles une
guerre dont Alexander et Ludmila
attendent la fin avec impatience
après la pause ils vivent au rythme des
sirènes et des bombes notre équipe s'est
rendue à horrible près d'un autre front
[Musique]
et Avenir le point sur les stratégies
militaires est-ce que le temps ne joue
pas en faveur de l'Ukraine
on parlait de harkieve nous nous sommes
allés sur un autre front plus au sud
dans la petite ville d'origine que les
rues stands de prendre depuis plusieurs
semaines ils avancent ils reculent la
situation est volatile mais cette ville
c'est un verrou si elle tombait cela
ouvrirait la voix vers la capitale
régionale zapporja qui est toujours sous
contrôle ukrainien près de 15000
personnes y habitaient avant les combats
aujourd'hui ceux qui sont toujours
vivent au rythme des sirènes et des
bombardements
tout semblait étonnamment calme quand
nous sommes entrés à horrir pourtant de
jour en jour la guerre se rapproche
sur la place centrale quelques fermiers
ont même installé leur étage ce matin
les jours de marché avant d'y aller la
place était pleine de monde les gens
venaient de partout autour
aujourd'hui chacun se dépêche de faire
quelques courses
et je ne souhaite qu'une chose dit-elle
c'est la paix
quelques instants plus tard
[Musique]
la sirène d'alerte
c'est le temps de rentrer pas de panique
juste de la résignation
[Musique]
Tamara qui espérait faire quelques sous
aujourd'hui ramasse lentement ces
produits
si chaque jour la même chose nous
dit-elle un peu excédé des sirènes des
bombes on ne peut pas dormir c'est
terrifiant
nous nous dirigeons vers les quartiers
plus près de la ligne de front
à l'aube c'est un jardin d'enfant qui a
été touché les Russes y ont largué une
bombe heureusement l'endroit était vide
il n'y a pas eu de victimes
pendant que nous sommes là les tirs se
rapprochent les Russes ont pratiquement
désertes une bonne partie de la
population a déjà quitté la ville les
femmes et les enfants surtout il reste
les hommes qui doivent se battre et
beaucoup de personnes âgées qui n'ont
pas les moyens de s'en aller qui se
retrouvent dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles
les échanges sont incessants les Russes
viennent de frapper cette entrepôt de
semences le blé devait servir à nourrir
la population locale
la voie ferrée a été endommagée et le
voisinage brûle cela fait des jours que
les combats se poursuivent ainsi les
Ukrainiens résistent en face de les trop
Prusses seraient importantes elles
occupent déjà trois villages autour et
si ory-rive tombait Moscou pourrait
élargir le territoire déjà contrôlé par
les séparatistes prorus du don-basse
mais la mairesse nous assure sans le
moindre doute que cela n'arrivera pas
alors
nous sommes plus forts on est chez nous
dit-elle et nous sommes Ukrainiens on
l'était on l'est on va le rester
de retour plus près du front dans les
immeubles abandonnés seuls quelques
personnes âgées s'aventurent à
l'extérieur la plupart dépendent de
l'aide humanitaire pour survivre 0 et ne
sont plus que trois femmes dans ce
bâtiment dit Valentine elle s'occupe de
sa mère de 87 ans et ne veut pas s'en
aller
qui peut nous aider à arrêter cette
guerre dit-elle et des nous j'ai mes
enfants mes petits-enfants et je ne peux
pas les voir c'est trop dangereux
comme tous ceux qui restent Valentina se
prépare au prochain bombardement mais
personne ici ne comprend pourquoi la
Russie s'acharne sur eux il menait une
vie si tranquille avant
Céline Galipeau Radio-Canada horizon
et dans cette guerre le temps joue-t-il
en faveur de l'Ukraine plus il en passe
plus le pays reçoit du matériel neuf et
moderne et aussi de l'entraînement
nécessaire pour l'utiliser mais plus de
temps veut aussi dire plus de victimes
civiles on l'a vu encore en fin de
semaine une frappe russe a détruit une
école dans la région de Louane et 60
personnes qui s'étaient réfugiées ont
été tués plus de morts chez les
militaires aussi du côté russe les
pertes sont impressionnantes le point
maintenant sur l'offensive avec
Jean-Michel au prince
les soldats Ukrainiens dans les
tranchées de la première ligne face à
donies occupé par l'armée russe nous
l'avait dit nous sommes prêts pour la
contre-offensive dès que l'ordre sera
donné
et ils sont passés à l'offensive près de
harkif assiégé par les Russes et à isium
sur la ligne de front de 400 km du
don-basse
parce qu'alors qu'on s'attendait à un
assaut massif on se rend compte que la
poussée russe n'en donne basse est
qualifiée d’anémique sur le 7 tentative
d'assaut qu'on a réussi à documenter en
essayant de faire la remontée des médias
sociaux on a vu qu'un investissement
deux qui avait réussi avec des avancées
pour les Russes qui sont minimes qui
sont de 1 à 2 km par jour donc ils sont
vraiment très réduites et puis
finalement souvent ça n'arrive pas à
être consolidé parce qu'à une
contre-offensive ukrainienne c'est ce
qu'on a vu à is you
au 75e jour de la guerre les Russes
n'ont pas beaucoup de réussite à
afficher
alors que les Ukrainiens se glorifient
de la destruction récente de deux
vedettes rapides en mer Noire
ainsi que du croiseur amiral mosfa
avec aussi des frappes à l'intérieur de
la Russie et la mort de 12 généraux
russes sur le terrain oui globalement un
mort toutes les semaines un général qui
meurt toutes les semaines mais ça c'est
simplement représentatif de ce qui se
passe tout en bas également on a
maintenant réussi à documenter la perte
de la part de la Russie de 3500 blindés
3500 blindés matériels des chars des
tanks des systèmes de défense des
systèmes d'artillerie c'est juste
colossal c'est plus qu'une armée comme
l'armée française qu'ils ont déjà perdu
aujourd'hui à côté de ça on estime qu'à
environ 15000 soldats russes qui sont
morts et environ 30 000 blessés plus
certains membres des centaines de
prisonniers donc tout ça fait que sur
les 150 180 000 hommes qui avaient été
engagés par la Russie bien
d'apprendrement un tiers qui sont
aujourd'hui totalement inaptés au combat
et le problème c'est que la Russie a
déjà engagé plus de la moitié de son
armée en Ukraine la lourde défaite des
environs de Kiev pourrait-elle se
reproduire dans l'Est et le Sud et on a
comme l'impression moi là je le
sentiment que j'ai c'est comme quand on
avait fait cette vidéo deux semaines
avant que la Russie renonce à prendre
Kiev moi j'ai l'impression qu'on est
dans la même situation dans le banc de
basse et autour de carpiff les Russes
donnent l'impression qu'ils sont dans
l'incapacité de continuer à avancer et
qu'il subisse des attaques de plus en
plus fréquentes et même pour le toucher
en attendant la vraie contre-offensive
est annoncée par le conseiller de la
présidente aulexie aristovitch pour la
nuit juin
[Musique]
le temps de recevoir et de se
familiariser avec le matériel militaire
moderne envoyé massivement par les
Alliés
alors que les sanctions contre la Russie
ont mis un terme à la production
d'avions et de blindés les plus modernes
faute de pièces indispensables venus de
l'Ouest le temps joue clairement en
faveur de l'Ukraine
[Musique]
Jean-Michel Lepas du Canada Montréal
une femme courageuse qu'on a appris à
connaître je me suis entretenu avec
Laeticia vassilenco
avenir la Moldavie sera-t-elle la
prochaine cible de Vladimir Poutine on
retrouve Tamara Alteresco sur place
et plus tard l'impact de cette guerre
sur la Suède avec marie-eveda un pays
neutre qui veut maintenant joindre
l'OTAN
elle est devenue une des voix qui porte
au cœur de ce conflit depuis le début de
l'invasion la députée ukrainienne laissa
va silenko a été de toutes les tribunes
pour dénoncer la brutalité des forces
russes les viols les exactions et
mobiliser la communauté internationale
nous lui avions parlé au tout début du
conflit et je l'ai retrouvé un peu plus
tôt aujourd'hui à Kiev
icia va sélenko ça nous fait plaisir de
vous retrouver ici à Kiev ça m'a fait
vraiment plaisir que vous êtes ici à
Kiev que vous avez eu l'opportunité de
voir un peu le pays et de voir comment
ça se passe à peu près dans tous les
partis qui sont vraiment affectés par
cette guerre d'agression russe ce matin
on a vu un défilé à Moscou pour le 9 mai
ou Vladimir Poutine rejette toute la
responsabilité de cette guerre il dit
que la menace était trop importante donc
c'est la faute de l'Occident comment
vous réagissez à ce qui s'est passé ce
matin mais c'est comme d'habitude il n'a
rien dit de nouveau il n'a rien dit
d'intéressant on a entendu cette
cassette là tournée plusieurs fois
plusieurs jours plusieurs années c'est
toujours la faute de quelqu'un mais pas
de Poutine et pas de la Russie en
témoigne à ce moment on lève les paroles
d'un dirigeant un peu lunatique et un
peu obsédé par le pouvoir et surtout un
dirigeant autoritaire qui voudrait bien
rétablir les empires mais ça fait 75
jours que ça dure ce conflit maintenant
quel bilan vous faites ça doit être
extrêmement fatigant c'est fatiguant
c'est dur mais nous les Ukrainiens on
n'a pas d'autre choix que de pousser à
la victoire et on le fait avec tous les
réseaux qu'on a ici on est vraiment
reconnaissant pour toute l'assistance
l'aide qu'on reçoit de l'étranger de nos
alliés mais c'est important aussi de
comprendre que le plus long que ça dure
le plus loin on sera de la victoire
puisque Poutine joue à son jeu qu'il a
commencé en 2014
quand il fait semblant de retirer ses
forces de localiser la guerre de
localiser la zone de combat et après ce
qu'on voit c'est que la tension
se diminue autour de l'Ukraine le
soutien aussi il y a ça commence à se
diminuer puisque les gars longues ça
coûte cher pour tout le monde et donc
moi je crains que c'est ce jeu là que
Poutine est en train de jouer avec le
monde entier vous créez une fatigue de
la communauté internationale de la
communauté internationale une fatigue en
une crâne aussi et à tout ça c'est c'est
un grand grand risque pour la victoire
de la démocratie on doit vraiment à ce
moment-là on doit vraiment mobiliser
tous les efforts du monde entier pour
pour avoir plus de armements en Ukraine
pour avoir vraiment des sanctions
effectives et trop fortes contre la
Russie et avoir surtout un soutien
économique pour l'Ukraine
on n'a pas de temps on doit avoir cette
victoire au plus vite possible est-ce
que vous pensez que si l'Occident et
j'inclus le Canada bien sûr là-dedans
avait agi plus vite avait aidé plus
l'Ukraine et plus vite on aurait pu
sauver des vies en graines je suis sûre
de ça tout le monde a fait un choix et
maintenant tout ce qui se passe ici en
Ukraine au milieu de l'Europe au milieu
du 21e siècle c'est la responsabilité
collective du monde entier qui a pas pu
agir autant aujourd'hui on voit ce qui
se passe encore à Mario Paul il y a
encore des soldats Ukrainiens qui
résistent est-ce que il va falloir qu'il
capitule devant la Russie est-ce que
c'est comme ça que ça va se terminer
selon vous ils ont pas le choix encore
une fois et ils ont que
se battre pour
soit gagner une victoire ou se battre à
la mort et ce sont les paroles de ces de
ses combattants de ces soldats de du
bataillon d'azove ils disent ils ont pas
peur de mourir mais ils sont parts
d'être pris en otage d'être prisonnier
par l'armée russe pourquoi parce que ça
serait pire que de mourir pour eux ça
serait beaucoup plus pire pour ils vont
être interrogés ils vont être torturés à
ça va être une mort mais une mort très
lente et
une mort très douloureuse pour eux et
prennent aussi que avec leur identité si
c'est déjà
vu par les Russes que leur famille et
leur gens proches vont être en danger
aussi au début de ce conflit on a vu des
images de vous vous étiez armées avec
une mitraillette ça avait beaucoup
marqué les esprits de voir une jeune
parlementaire comme vous prendre les
armes est-ce que ça vous a servi
finalement j'ai toujours mes armes je
je suis très heureuse de ne pas avoir du
m'en servir avec c'était vraiment les
semaines la première mois de cette
guerre
quand les Russes c'était tout près de
kievres
de Kiev vous avez pu le témoigner quand
vous êtes allé à Abu c'est vraiment très
très près c'est pratiquement qui donc il
y avait ces risques ces risques vraiment
très haut et il va aller mieux d'avoir
une arme pour pouvoir se protéger à ce
moment-là la situation a changé vous
voyez très bien la vie continue la ville
revient même avec les sons de guerre un
peu au background mais de toute façon
c'est beaucoup plus calme c'est beaucoup
plus sécurisé donc vous voyez moi je
porte pas de sacs à main avec un
pistolet dedans c'est plus c'est plus la
même chose mais vraiment la guerre
continue toujours vous avez dénoncé
justement des viols comme armes de
guerre de l'armée russe
quel est l'ampleur de ce phénomène les
Russes ils utilisent le viol comme une
arme de car il le faisait pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
ils le font maintenant 6 donc rien à
changer pour vraiment
pour
une femme et une personne d'être violée
parce que les Russes il viole et les
femmes les enfants les hommes
c'est c'est pire que d'être tué et quand
tu es violé
tu es victime pour le reste de ta vie
puisque c'était un crime qui était
commis contre toi contre ton corps
et cette marque en plus c'est violent
c'est pas juste
la résistance la résistance c'est fait
pour briser la personne se fait pour
briser les familles et les communautés
puisque c'est viol il se passe
devant les devant les autres gens devant
ta famille on a plein de cas de viols
qui où il y avait les filles qui étaient
violées devant leur mère ou les mers qui
étaient violées devant leur fils
donc quand la famille ou la communauté
doit survivre à ça il y a tout un bagage
qui reste et qui avec lequel on sait pas
quoi faire puisque il y a toujours ce
sentiment de
ça s'est passé devant mes yeux j'ai pas
rien pu faire pour protéger mon enfant
où j'ai plus rien faire pour protéger
cette femme qui est ma voisine dans ma
communauté comment est-ce que je peux
vivre après avec cela donc c'est tout
ce qui reste après les crimes de viol
c'est tout un long ruban de
problèmes qui vont qui vont se dérouler
pendant des années et des années
peut-être pendant des générations en
terminant vous pensez que les l'ukraines
va résister jusqu'au bout est-ce qu'elle
peut gagner cette guerre l'Ukraine doit
gagner cette gare pour nous pour les
Ukrainiens mais aussi pour que le monde
entier dans lequel on est habitué à se
vivre à reste
ce monde à quel on est habitué et reste
une place de
paix de sécurité
on doit rétablir la paix et c'est ça ce
qu'il y a avec avec la victoire
ukrainienne
merci beaucoup merci à vous avoir parlé
aujourd'hui
bonne chance merci merci
[Musique]
après la pause on retrouve tamarin en
Moldavie pays voisin du l'Ukraine qui
craint lui aussi la Russie
[Musique]
la crainte que le conflit déborde
au-delà des frontières de l'Ukraine
continue d'inquiéter les pays voisins
c'est le cas de la Moldavie une ancienne
république soviétique entourée par
l'Ukraine et la Roumanie où je joins à
nouveau Tamara Tamara c'est surtout ce
qui se passe en Transnistrie c'est une
petite enclave séparatiste prorus de la
Moldavie qu'il faut surveiller et vous
avez pu entrer sur le territoire
oui on nous avait dit que c'était
presque impossible d'y aller étant donné
que l'état d'alerte est en vigueur
depuis deux semaines déjà mais on a
réussi en sous prétexte qu'on était là
comme touriste et c'est important pour
nous d'aller voir comment vit cette
population vous savez c'est pas une
partie du monde à laquelle on s'était on
s'intéresse souvent mais qui
vraisemblablement pourrait devenir le
prochain front pour la Russie dans cette
guerre contre l'Ukraine et ce qu'on y a
trouvé c'est une population bien sûr qui
est très proriste très patriotique parce
qu'elle dépend grandement du point de
vue économique de la Russie mais qui n'a
aucun désir en tout cas d'après tout ce
qu'on a pu constater d'être impliqué
dans cette guerre mais pourrait être
entraîné bien malgré elle vous savez il
y a plusieurs scénarios qui sont
anticipés de un qu'on se sert de la
Transnistrie où il y a déjà des soldats
russes parce qu'il maintienne la paix
depuis 30 ans qu'on se sert de la
Transnistrie pour attaquer au dessin ça
c'est un des scénarios envisager l'autre
encore pire serait qu'on se sert de la
Transnistrie pour envahir la Moldavie
carrément donc c'est le risque avec
lequel les autorités moldavres doivent
composer depuis quelques semaines déjà
il y a une série d'explosion en
Transnistrie des provocations qui de
toute évidence sert à créer le chaos
donc malgré son désir de neutralité face
aux conflits en Ukraine c'est une
réalité qui devient de plus de plus en
plus préoccupante pour les gens ici
mais vraiment quels sont les risques à
ce statut que les forces russes entrent
en Moldavie
il n'est le risque n'est pas imminent
mais il est réel disons-le comme ça
surtout depuis qu'on a entendu ce
général russe il y a deux semaines dire
que c'est important pour la Russie
d'occuper le sud de l'Ukraine parce que
ça donnerait une porte d'entrée en
Moldavie vous savez je vous parlais de
dessin un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui c'est
clé aussi de surveiller la bataille pour
redescendre on est en train on a
l'impression que dessin est en train de
devenir la prochaine Mario Paul plus il
est trop avancent vers des sommes plus
il y a un risque que le conflit déborde
ici en Moldavie en passant par en
passant par la Transnistrie donc on y
est allé on vous présente demain un
reportage
alors on regardera ça merci beaucoup
Tamara
au revoir
[Musique]
et
un autre pays qui craint Moscou la Suède
songe maintenant à joindre l'OTAN on en
parle avec Marie-Ève Bédard après la
pause
[Musique]
l'impact de cette invasion se fait
sentir jusqu'en Finlande et en Suède ce
sont deux pays historiquement neutres
mais qui envisagent maintenant de se
joindre à l'OTAN la Suède est d'ailleurs
sur le point d'annoncer sa décision ça
se fera dimanche prochain ce qui va être
assez désastreux pour Moscou puisque
c'est justement pour éviter d'avoir le
temps à ses portes que la Russie a
envahi l'Ukraine Marie-Ève Bédard est à
Stockholm Marie-Ève il faut le souligner
c'est quand même un revirement majeur là
pour la Suède
les Suédois sont très attachées à cette
politique à cette doctrine
d'une non-aminement avec le temps mais
de plus en plus on constate depuis le
début du conflit les perspectives ici
changent c'est important comme
transformation de la société qui est
toujours été très attachée à cette
espèce de neutralité qui lors donnait
l'impression de pouvoir plus librement
jouer les diplomates du monde de ne pas
avoir à s'attacher à des causes
militaires au-delà de ce que le pays
soit lui-même pouvait décider pour le
parti au pouvoir le Parti
social-démocrate qui s'est fait tout au
long de sa carrière le porte étendard de
ce non alignement à l'OTAN c'est aussi
une transformation très profonde ce qui
explique aussi peut-être pourquoi la
Suède se montre moins volontaire dans
ces déclarations mais peu de surprises
on pense que dimanche le pays va
annoncer qu'ils vont faire cette demande
d'adhésion en le temps
Kamila n'avait pas prévu passer les
premiers jours ensoleillés du printemps
avec une arme à la main mais c'est de
vendeuse de fromage et jambon dans un
supermarché se dit rassuré de pouvoir
consacrer le prochain mois à parfaire le
maniement des armes
[Applaudissements]
c'est important dit-elle parce que je
veux faire quelque chose au lieu de
rester à la maison et m'inquiéter de ne
pas savoir quoi faire ou ce qui va se
passer
ce qui l'inquiète c'est la Russie Camila
fait partie des réservistes de la
défense territoriale de la Suède en
temps normal elle doit consacrer
quelques jours par année à
l'entraînement mais ça ne suffit plus à
décider son pays
c'est tout près de chez nous alors c'est
devenu une réalité dijonnette c'est
inquiétant mais je n'ai pas peur
j'en ai aussi et volontaire et ne vient
pas seule ces deux chiennes entraînaient
à la détection de drogue d'explosifs
pourraient aussi se porter à la défense
de la Suède
à utiliser la force militaire pour
atteindre ses objectifs politiques comme
Gotland a une grande importance
stratégique bien sûr qu'il faut se
préparer
au temps de la guerre froide la Suède
avait déployé jusqu'à 25000 de ses
soldats sur l'île quand elle a pris fin
Gotland a été complètement démilitarisés
d'approche et qui se soit détourné de la
Défense nationale pour participer à des
opérations militaires internationales
fait valoir le commandant mais dans la
situation actuelle que nous vivons
c'était une erreur
[Applaudissements]
ce que le commandant qualifie d'erreur a
été rectifié en 2014 après l'annexion de
la Crimée par la Russie aujourd'hui 200
soldats de l'armée régulière sont en
poste à Gotland ils seront bientôt
beaucoup plus nombreux le gouvernement
suédois vient d'annoncer avoir mis de
côté 163 millions d'euros
supplémentaires soit plus de 220
millions de dollars pour renforcer ses
infrastructures militaires sur l'île
si Gotland dans plein cœur de la mer
Baltique reçoit aujourd'hui au temps
d'attention c'est qu'elle est située à
quelques 300 km de l'enclave russe de
Kaliningrad et ces deux là que la Russie
pourrait bien mettre à exécution ces
menaces de riposte si la Suède décidait
de se joindre le temps
au-delà des côtes du Gotland il est là
le débat qui émerge à la surface pour la
Suède aujourd'hui tout comme la Finlande
voisine le pays scandinave a fait de la
non adhésion le temps une véritable
doctrine pendant des décennies mais le
gouvernement social démocrate serait sur
le point de rompre avec cette tradition
de neutralité militaire l'opinion
publique suédoise aussi a basculé de
façon importante depuis l'invasion russe
en Ukraine un Suédois sur deux se dit
aujourd'hui en faveur du jamais vu
d'abord nous avons vu que l'Ukraine
n'était pas protégée par le temps nous
avons compris que nous ne le saurions
sans doute pas non plus nous avons aussi
vu que la menace était réelle pas que
des paroles et ensuite nous avons vu les
provocations et les menaces de la Russie
depuis longtemps mais il est allé trop
loin alors nous n'avons pas pris peur
nous nous sommes fâchés expliquent-ils
une colère que partage cette député
suédoise ou Parlement européen il y a un
mois et le fouet le sol de boucha en
banlieue de elle en est revenu hantée
par les crimes de guerre qui ont été
commisha dit-elle la même chose est en
train de se reproduire ailleurs en
Ukraine pendant que nous sommes ici
c'est très douloureux
de citoyens suédois et réfugiés
ukrainien rassemblés au centre de
Stockholm par un samedi pluvieux Karine
Corse Brown avait cependant pas besoin
de voir les horreurs de la guerre en
Ukraine pour soutenir l'adhésion de son
pays à l'OTAN le Parti libéral dont elle
est membre militent depuis longtemps en
faveur de l'alliance militaire
ce qui s'est passé en Ukraine à
réveiller la société suédoise
si tous sont visiblement comme elle
bouleversée par le centre de l'Ukraine
il ne partage pas nécessairement son
enthousiasme pour le temps
un peu à l'image des propos des
dirigeants suédois Gillian paraît plus
résigné camballé à l'idée d'abandonner
la neutralité de la Suède il le faut
dit-elle mais c'est le sacrifice d'un
idéal
[Musique]
il y a tant d'aspects que je n'aime pas
mais j'ai peur pour la Finlande aussi et
je ne vais pas l'abandonner si elle
rejoint le temps
[Musique]
le choix est douloureux pour beaucoup
mais il semble aujourd'hui qu'il sera
sans surprise la Suède doit annoncer sa
décision dimanche prochain
et vous pouvez nous suivre sur les
réseaux sociaux sur la page facebook
Radio-Canada information sur mon compte
Twitter et sur Instagram ou Radio-Canada
info vous pouvez également revoir notre
Téléjournal sur la page web
radio-canada.ch
et en terminant un honneur bien mérité
un prix pour les heures spécial a été
décerné à l'ensemble des journalistes
Ukrainiens pour souligner leur courage
dans la couverture de l'invasion de leur
pays l'association a salué leur
engagement à rapporter les faire
apporter la vérité malgré la propagande
russe 12 journalistes je vous rappelle
dans 8 Ukrainiens aurait été tués depuis
le début de cette guerre voilà c'est ce
qui met fin à ce Téléjournal depuis Kiev
en Ukraine et à ma couverture ici c'est
Jean-François Bélanger qui va continuer
à suivre les événements pour vous ça a
été un privilège vraiment d'avoir pu
passer du temps sur le terrain pour
sentir pour mieux comprendre comment se
vit cette guerre merci à l'équipe qui
m'a accompagné merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi bonsoir à bientôt
[Musique]